All right, gentlemen,
today you will be competing
in our san mai challenge.
So on your anvils,
there's a cloth.
Go ahead and lift that up.
Those are high-carbon
drill bits.
And there's a soft steel
billet inside that box.
The san mai challenge is forging
blades in your signature styled
by sandwiching soft steel
around a hardenable steel
core and edge.
TIM: I am in so much trouble
(LAUGHING) right now.
I have never, ever messed
with the drill bits.
Just getting those
straightened out
and getting them
into a billet is
going to be a challenge enough.
I'm in trouble.
All right, bladesmiths,
grab your steel.
Your 10-minute design
window starts now.
I'm going to go to my standard
go-to blade, which is a seax.
As far as chopping-- it's going
to have some weight to it.
And as far as slicing--
if I put the right edge to
it, the right angle on it,
she'll slice just great.
Bladesmiths, the
design period is closed.
Your three-hour forge
time starts now.
[music playing]
- Eeny-meeny-miney, right?
- Yeah.
So there's Tim.
This is what I like to see.
He's cleaning up his steel.
He's going to get
some very clean welds.
TIM: I'm cleaning up, simply
because if you don't, then
you run the risk of
getting some inclusions
in there when you actually
go to heat it up and weld it.
Just one little
spot's all it takes.
Just mig welded my
first billet together
out of those drill bits.
That's honestly the first
time I'd ever gotten
to play with a mig welder.
Those things are pretty cool.
If I can win it, I'm buying one.
This forge here has
so much more than I
have (LAUGHING) at my own.
I don't have a hydraulic press.
I don't have a power hammer.
I'm used to doing
everything by hand.
That could be my Achilles
heel, I don't know.
(YELLING) Bladesmiths, you
only have two hours remaining
to finish your blades.
We hit that hour mark,
and I'm feeling like--
where did I slow down?
My billet is thicker than I
thought it was going to be.
And so it's just taking
its own sweet time
getting to that temperature
where I can start moving it.
Come on!
Come on, come on, come on.
That clock on the wall--
it's like having a ton
sitting on your head.
I'm behind the eight
ball on this one.
Tim's working that seax
tip into his blade now.
I got the bevels rough-forged,
and the handle's in there.
Wish it was a little
bit wider on the tip.
Thought I was going to
have at least a half hour
to address anything
that I wanted to.
I don't have that time anymore.
(YELLING) 10
minutes, bladesmiths.
TIM: I've got to get this
blade heated up and quenched.
- Oh no!
- Yes!
Look, Tim is in the oil.
Tim is our first
smith to quench.
I'm really surprised by that.
So far, so good.
WIL WILLIS: (YELLING) 10,
9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, drop your tools.
This forging round is over.
[applause]
[interposing voices]
Damn!
WIL WILLIS: Bladesmiths,
it's time for the judges
to take a closer
look at your work.
Alan, you're up first.
Please present your
work to the judges.
BEN ABBOTT: I really
enjoyed watching
you do your forge welds.
Everything seemed
to be going well,
and then something
must have happened.
Because this is really thin.
For a coconut chop, I
might have wanted it just
a little bit thicker than that.
All right, Ed, please present
your work to the judges.
Well, Ed, I like where
you're heading with this knife.
I like the shape.
But I mean, there's deep
fissures on the top here.
And I'm not 100% sure
that it's welded.
There's almost
rattling in there.
(WHISPERING) Yeah, well.
WIL WILLIS: All
right, Tim, you're up.
DAVID BAKER: I liked where
you were going with this.
But I would have loved to
have seen that peak being
up here another three-quarters
of an inch to really give
it that brokeback seax look.
If you move forward, try
not to lose too much mass.
One thing I'm not a huge
fan of is this handle.
It's a little small for my hand.
Be interesting to see
if there's anything
that can be done there.
But all in all, it's a
solidly welded piece.
Well done.
Bladesmiths, the judges
deliberation is complete,
and they've made
their final decision.
It's time for one of
you to leave the forge.
The bladesmith leaving
the forge is Ed.
Your blade did not make the cut.
David Baker is going
to tell you why.
Ed, I really appreciate
all the work you
did to set up for that weld.
But with that material being
so thin, some of those welds
are questionable.
And all four of our blades,
yours is the least finished.
And that's why we're
letting you go.
Ed, please
surrender your blade.
This experience was
the heat in my life
I needed to forge
myself into a better
person and a better knifemaker.
It may have saved my life.
I'll never stop making knives.